trabajemos con este problema que tiene
que ver con funciones exponenciales dice
liam abre una cuenta de ahorros en donde
deposita 6 mil 250 pesos 6 mil 250 pesos
esto va a ser importante cada año su
cuenta crece un 20% cada año su cuenta
crece un 20 por ciento cuántos años
necesitarán para obtener una cuenta con
12 mil 960 pesos
escribe una ecuación que modela la
situación usa t para representar el
número de años desde que elián abre la
cuenta y bueno me gustaría que tú
intentará resolver este problema por ti
mismo así que es buen momento para que
pases este vídeo e intente resolverlo
así vas a ver si llegamos a la misma
respuesta así que pagos el vídeo y voy a
empezar a resolver lo justo
ok vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con
liam en un primer año y déjame ponerlo
con este color si nosotros empezamos en
el año cero justo en el momento en el
que el día abre la cuenta
bueno pues liam tiene seis mil 250 pesos
entonces lo voy a poner aquí empezó con
6 mil 250 pesos de lujo ahora después de
que pase un año en el año 1
liam ya no va a tener solamente 6 mil
250 pesos va a tener estos mismos 6 mil
250 pesos pero además fíjate que esta
cuenta crece con un 20% es decir va a
tener más 20% de estos a 6 mil 250 pesos
déjame ponerlo con este color de estos
mismos 6 mil 250 pesos ahora quiero que
te des cuenta que esto podemos
escribirlo de la siguiente manera esto
es exactamente lo mismo si yo factor
hizo precisamente este 6 mil 250
6.250 que multiplica bueno en primer
lugar a uno va a multiplicar a uno que
es sí mismo este de aquí va a
multiplicar a uno y después va a
multiplicar al 20% ahora recuerda que el
20% lo podemos escribir como en 0.20 el
0.20 visto en su forma decimal y es que
esto se le facilita mucho más porque
ahora puedo escribir esta misma ecuación
esta misma igualdad como 6.250 que
multiplica a 1.2 que multiplica a 1.2 ok
va a multiplicar a esta cantidad o este
valor de aquí ahora vamos a pensar qué
es lo que pasa en el transcurso del
segundo año cuando llegamos al final del
segundo año el dinero del día va a
volver a cambiar y cómo va a volver a
cambiar
bueno pues esencialmente lo que va a
pasar es que vamos a tener la misma
cantidad que nosotros ganamos en el
primer año
esta cantidad de aquí es decir a 1 y la
vamos a multiplicar otra vez por 1
todos que es la tasa de crecimiento a
esto lo vamos a multiplicar por 1.2 por
1.2 y bueno esto nos va a quedar esto va
a ser exactamente lo mismo que 6 mil 250
que 6 mil 250 que a su vez multiplica a
1.2 que a su vez multiplica a 1.2 que a
su vez multiplica a 1.2 a este 1.2 que
sube multiplica a 1.2 y bueno esto lo
podemos escribir esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 6 mil 250 de 6.250 que
multiplica a 1.2 que multiplica a 1.2
elevado al cuadrado 1.2 por 1.2 es 1.2
elevado al cuadrado ahora ya te puedes
imaginar qué es lo que pasa después que
transcurra el tercer año en el año 3
bueno pues creo que ya te puedes dar
cuenta el patrón cuando transcurra el
tercer año lo que va a pasar es que
vamos a seguir teniendo 6000
50 pesos pero ahora lo voy vamos a
multiplicar por 1.2 por 1.2 elevado al
cubo al cubo por que estamos en el
tercer año entonces ya podemos
generalizar ya podemos pensar que es lo
que va a pasar en el año temp como
queremos saber cuántos años y vamos a
usar t para representar ese número de
años en el año temp nosotros sabemos que
esto va a ser igual a 6.250 por 1.2 por
1.2 estamos siguiendo el patrón elevado
a la t elevado a la t que es la cantidad
de años ahora esta es la típica fórmula
del interés compuesto sin embargo en
esta ocasión tenemos hasta qué cantidad
queremos llegar queremos obtener 12 mil
960 pesos por lo tanto lo que quiero es
que esta cantidad que estamos poniendo
justo aquí sea igual a 12 mil 960 pesos
a 12 mil
960 pesos o dicho de otra manera y si
escribimos bien la ecuación me va a
quedar que 12 mil 960 pesos esto tiene
que ser igual tiene que ser igual a 6000
256.250 ok que multiplica que multiplica
a 1.2 que multiplica a 1.2 elevado a la
tem y justo lo que queremos saber es la
cantidad de años es decir t
ok ahora estas ecuaciones de aquí son
ecuaciones exponenciales y se le conocen
como ecuaciones exponenciales porque lo
que nosotros buscamos está en el
exponente de hecho está justo aquí y
bueno hay varias formas de resolver
ecuaciones exponenciales y sería muy
bueno que tú aprendieras bien cómo
responderlas ahora lo que se me ocurre
en primer lugar es pasar este 6.250 del
otro lado dividiendo para que me quede
solamente lo que tiene que ver con la
potencia del lado derecho y lo voy a
poner primero me va a quedar que 1.21.2
elevado a la t elevado a la t esto es
exactamente lo mismo esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 6.250 déjame cambiar a ese
mismo color a 12.960 12.960 y éste lo
voy a pasar del otro lado dividiendo es
decir estoy dividiendo todo entre 6.250
y bueno lo padre de esto es que seis mil
doscientos cincuenta y éste son
divisibles
así que vamos a quitar estos ceros de
una vez que nos estorban este cero no lo
quiero por ahorita ok y este cero
tampoco lo quiero por ahorita entonces
me voy a quedar solamente con esta
expresión que tengo aquí 1.2 tm es igual
a 1.296 entre 625 para no confundirnos
voy a quitar también está command y la
voy a poner justo aquí o que es una coma
que está aquí muy bien y cuánto es esto
pues a qué te parece si sacamos la
calculadora y vemos cómo podemos
resolver esta ecuación lo primero que
quiero saber es cuánto es mil 296 mil
296 entre 625 así que vamos a traer la
calculadora que ya tengo justo por aquí
y con esta vamos a poder ayudarnos a
resolver este problema cuánto es mil 296
entre o dónde está el entre entre 625
bueno esto es lo mismo que dos puntos
736 ok yo lo que quiero es elevar 1.2 a
una cierta cantidad de años y que me de
2.073 6 y bueno para resolver este tipo
de ecuaciones exponenciales hay varias
formas de hacerlo sin embargo quiero que
en una primera instancia lo hagamos de
una manera muy intuitiva si yo lo que
quiero es encontrar el valor de t que te
parece si multiplicamos 1.2 por sí mismo
cuantas veces sea necesario hasta que
lleguemos a este valor de aquí así que
voy a multiplicar esto por 1.2 y me da
ok
1.44 todavía no llegamos a ver 1.2 por x
no este es el menos vamos a borrar por
1.2
por está aquí en 1.2 esto me dan 1.7 28
a ver otra vez 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2 por
1.2 si lo multiplicamos por sí mismo 4
veces
de lujo es justo lo que yo quería llegar
a 2.07 36 es este mismo valor
por lo tanto 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2
es decir 1.2 elevado a la cuarta
potencia es justo el resultado que yo
quiero y ahora lo puedo escribir aquí
déjame a borrar este punto y voy a poner
entonces que te la cantidad de años que
yo quiero es igual a 4 que es lo mismo
que 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2 por 1.2 ok bueno
esta es una forma de resolverlo ahora
también hay otras formas de resolverlo
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla para
que lo veas la siguiente forma que
quiero que veamos de cómo se resuelve
este tipo de problemas
ok bajemos la pantalla es pensar en cómo
podemos ver a uno
2 que se parezca a esta expresión de
aquí y bueno es que 1.2 lo podemos ver
como 6 quintos esto sería lo mismo
déjame ponerlo con este color que 6
sobre 5 sobre 5 elevado a la t elevado a
la t y es que aquí me acabo de dar
cuenta que la potencia de abajo tiene
que ver tiene que ver con el 5 625
cuánto es bueno pues déjeme cambiar de
color
si yo saco el 625 5 x 5
es lo mismo que 25 ok 25 por 5 es lo
mismo que 125 y es que me acabo de dar
cuenta que 125 por 5
es lo mismo que 625 o sea que esta
expresión de aquí la puedo ver
exactamente igual como 6 como 6 elevado
a una cierta potencia entre 5 elevado y
entre 5 elevado a la cuarta potencia
a la cuarta potencia y qué crees mil 296
que es lo mismo que seis elevado a la
cuarta potencia y justo en este momento
puedo decir que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que seis déjame ponerlo con este
color que seis hombres cinco ok que 6
sobre 5 sobre 5 todo esto todo esto
elevado a la cuarta potencia elevado a
la cuarta potencia y bueno si tengo 6
sobre 5 elevado late es lo mismo que 6
sobre 5 en la cuarta potencia entonces
este y tiene que ser igual a 4 y dedujo
ya van dos veces que llegó a la misma
respuesta déjame ponerlo con mucho
cuidado te tiene que ser igual a 4 aquí
otra forma de resolver este tipo de
ecuaciones exponenciales ahora se me
ocurre que hay otra forma infalible de
resolver este tipo de ecuaciones
exponenciales en este caso me salió que
t es un número exacto sin embargo no
siempre debe de ser un número exacto en
una ecuación exponencial por lo tanto la
forma infalible
la cual siempre sale la respuesta de
este tipo de problemas es la siguiente
lo que voy a hacer es sacar la
calculadora y de hecho ya hemos probado
en varios vídeos sobre logaritmos esto
que voy a utilizar lo que voy a utilizar
es sacar el logaritmo en base 10 y lo
que voy a hacer es sacar el logaritmo en
base 10 am de ambos lados de esta
ecuación y es que entonces el consejo
que te doy es que para sacar el
logaritmo en base 10 y saber la solución
de este problema tenemos que hacer lo
siguiente poner el logaritmo en base 10
de quien bueno tenemos esta división 1
296 que es a su vez divide a 625 ok es
esta parte derecha y después a esto a
esto hay que dividirlo entre logaritmo
envase 10 de la base que tiene el
exponente es decir 1.2 1.2 y en varios
vídeos de khan academy he visto justo
esto
esto nos sirve para resolver cualquier
tipo de ecuación exponencial y si yo le
pongo enfermedad 4 exacto que es justo
nuestro resultado si pongo ahora la
calculadora para acá me acaba de decir
de nuevo la calculadora de una tercer
manera como podemos encontrar la
solución de este tipo de problemas
utilizando el logaritmo en base 10 y
bueno déjame ponértelo otra vez por aquí
porque tal vez esto parece un poco de
vudú o algo muy raro pero está
impresionante y tú te lo puedes aprender
así para poder resolver cualquier tipo
de ecuación exponencial lo único que
hice fue tomarme el lado derecho ok la
parte que no tiene que ver con el
exponente y puse el logaritmo en base 10
de la parte que está en el lado derecho
de igual manera puede haber puesto
logaritmo en base 10 de 2.07
a 36 que era la división de estos dos ok
ya eso lo divide y aquí está el gran
consejo que te doy hay que dividirlo
entre el lugar ismo en base de 10 de la
base que tiene el exponente de 1.2 y
entonces vamos a llegar al resultado que
nosotros queremos es resultados 4 y
bueno en este caso 4 es un número
bastante buena onda pero nosotros
podríamos tener 3.9 3.725 o cualquier
loquera y con esta forma de resolver
ecuaciones exponenciales siempre vamos a
llegar al resultado